there are only so many major political
events globally each year and we have
one that is transpiring right now the
british prime minister boris johnson of
the conservative party colloquially
known as the tories has announced that
he's going to resign his party has lost
confidence in him it has been
humiliation after humiliation and up
until the last moment boris johnson was
saying resign why no why would i resign
and he is now resigned or he will resign
once a replacement is found um a very uh
good report about this from the
associated press britain's boris johnson
resigning as prime minister amid scandal
this is another trumpist type
whose political run is at least for now
ending in completely humiliating defeat
of course you know pending what happens
with trump in 2024 there may be more
written in the trump story but this is
another
trump in type
who is getting humiliated out of office
prime minister boris johnson announced
his resignation thursday
amid a mass revolt by top members of his
government marking an end to three
tumultuous years in power in which he
brazenly bent and sometimes broke the
rules of british politics months of
defiance ended almost with a shrug as
johnson stood in 10 downing street and
conceded that his party wanted him gone
let's look at a bit of that announcement
and yeah i i the the ap
very uh accurately saying it was months
of defiance and this sort of faux
principled indignant defiance resign
i am here to do a job for the people of
the
yeah i guess i'm gone
i don't know good afternoon
it thank you thank you
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister right i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our back bench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now and the
timetable will be announced next week
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
so i want to say to the millions of
people who voted for us in 2019 many of
them voting conservative for the first
time thank you
for that incredible mandate yeah i mean
the message should be to those who voted
for the tories for the first time
you're probably never going to do it
again the biggest conservative majority
since 1987
the biggest share of the vote since
1979.
yeah so uh there it is boris johnson
resigning in shame a little bit more
from the associated press article
the brash 58 year old who took britain
out of the eu and steered it through
covet and the war in ukraine was brought
down by one scandal too many
this one involving his appointment of a
politician who had been accused of
sexual misconduct now i have to tell you
in reading through this johnson is a
sort of british version of trump in many
ways not just the hair uh the kind of
brash
never apologize type nature and you know
the sort of pseudo right wing stuff yeah
but i have to tell you at this point
american politics has fallen so far like
into the toilet for lack of a better
term people are flushing toilets 10
times 15 times american politics are so
in the toilet that if trump had done the
exact same things johnson did i don't
know that it would have been even a
fraction of the big deal that it became
in the uk
uh the messiest of prime ministers did
not leave cleanly the article says
johnson stepped down immediately as
conservative party leader
but said he would remain as prime
minister until the party chooses his
successor the timetable could be
announced next week from what i'm
reading we could be talking about months
during which a it's a sort of lame duck
by by self-designation
situation there he could be there for
months still many in the party wanted
him gone before then his government has
been shredded by scores of resignations
and there's a long long list of those
johnson clung to power for two days
defiantly telling lawmakers wednesday he
had a colossal mandate from voters
massive dumps of votes he had guys and
intended to get on with the business of
government but he was forced to concede
defeat thursday after one of his closest
allies newly appointed treasury chief
nadim zahawi
publicly told him to resign for the good
of the country look at these numbers
about 50 cabinet secretaries ministers
and lower level officials had quit the
government over the past few days often
castigating the prime minister for his
lack of integrity so a very interesting
and big story
the real the most relevant question
arguably
globally about this resignation
is okay so you replace johnson with
someone less cartoonish
but does the uk's
positioning
in geopolitics change on any major issue
does do trade relationships change in
any major way as a result of this no
probably not um does the british
position on the ukrainian uh defense
against the russian invasion change no
probably not um and so it is a very
it's a personally scandal-ridden
individual who's now going to be
replaced but there's really no reason to
think that in any substantive capacity
um the uk's geopolitical positioning is
going to change and you could say well
that's a good thing or that's a bad
thing or stability is good but actually
change would be good because the uk has
become much more right-wing than many of
us on the left would like to see
um
we'll have to see where the dominos sort
of fall as far as that goes but this is
primarily
uh a personal scandal
with within the context of the
conservative party who will now choose a
new leader and subsequently there will
be a new prime minister now there could
be follow-on effects uh at the time of
the next election and depending on what
happens within the united states in
terms of the midterms in 2024 you could
certainly see a shifting dynamic in the
relationship between the uk and the us
and in the uk's positioning globally
none of that is happening right now this
is johnson is out he will be replaced
other than again the sort of like
cartoonish nature of johnson i don't
anticipate based on everything i'm
reading right now that there will be any
radical or substantive changes certainly
to our relationship with the uk but not
a good couple of days for boris johnson
and very much like trump defiant until
the final moment
with trump it was well
making every claim about how he was
going to stay in power because he really
won and then just quietly leaving not
even going to the inauguration with
boris johnson
for weeks and weeks
remaining indignant about well what do
you mean resign
two days even when it was clear the
pressure was overwhelming saying why
would i resign and then i'm out and
we'll see what the next step is
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever spend
time planning it when what time of day
do i need to take each one i just get it
all with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then i'm just good for
the day it supports gut health and i'm
getting everything that i need and i'm
looking for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below